your attention for example is mediated
by unconscious forces and you know that
you know that perfectly well and this is
another freudian observation you know if
you're
sitting down
to study
for example your conscious intent is to
study but you know perfectly well that
all sorts of distraction fantasies are
going to enter the theater of your
imagination non-stop and annoyingly and
and there isn't really a lot you can do
about that except maybe wait it out you
know so you'll be sitting there reading
and
your attention will flicker away you'll
think about i don't know maybe you want
to watch jane the virgin on netflix or
something like that or maybe it's time
to have a peanut butter sandwich or you
should get the dust bunnies from out
from underneath the bed or it's time to
go outside and have a cigarette or maybe
it's time for a cup of coffee or it's
like all these subsystems in you that
would like something aren't
very happy just to sit there while you
read this thing that you're actually
bored by and so they pop up and try to
take control of your perceptions and
your actions non-stop maybe you think
well this is a stupid course anyways why
do i have to read this damn paper and
what am i doing in university and what's
the point of life it's like you can
really well you can really get going if
you're trying to avoid doing your
homework and and
and then you might think well what is it
in you that's trying to avoid because
after all you took the damn course and
you told yourself to sit down why don't
you listen
well because you're you're a mess
that's basically why
you haven't got control over yourself at
all
and no more than i have control over
this laptop
okay so there's the memory function of
of of the unconscious and there's the
dissolutive function that's an
interesting one the unconscious contains
habits once voluntary now automatized
and dissociated elements of the
personality which may lead to parasitic
existence that's an interesting one i
would relate that more to procedural
memory you know so what you've done is
practice certain habits whatever they
might be let's call them bad habits and
you like those things to get under
control but you can't so maybe when
you're speaking for example you use like
and you know and you say i'm a lot and
you've practiced that so you're really
good at it and you'd like to stop it but
you don't get to because you've built
that little machine right into your
being right it's neurologically wired
and it's not under conscious control and
anything you practice
becomes that it becomes part of you and
and that's another element of the
unconscious a different part
and then there's a creative part which
is that well you know you're sitting
around and maybe you're trying to write
something or maybe you want to
produce a piece of art or a piece of
music or maybe you're just laying in bed
dreaming and you have all these weird
ideas and especially in dreams it's like
what where do those things come from and
even more strange
one of the things that's really weird
about dreams and almost impossibly weird
is that you're an observer in the dream
it's like a dream is something that
happens to you well you're dreaming it
theoretically so how is it that you can
be an observer it's almost like you're
watching a video game or a movie but
you're producing it that at least in
principle although the psychoanalyst
would say well no not exactly your ego
isn't producing it your unconscious is
producing it's a different thing
it's a different thing and of course
jung would say well it's deeper than
that the collective unconscious might be
producing it it's in some sense it isn't
you exactly or it isn't the you that you
think of when you think of you and
that's the ego from the freudian
perspective the you that you identify
with that's the ego
and outside of that is the unconscious
the id
that's more the place of impulses and
you could think about those as the
biological sub-systems that can derail
your thinking right and that govern
things like hunger and sex and
aggression and your basic instincts is
another way of putting it and it's a
reasonable way of thinking about it
because these are sub-systems that you
share with with animals you share them
certainly with mammals you share most of
them with reptiles you share a lot of
them with amphibians and even going all
the way down to crustaceans there's
commonality for example in the dominance
hierarchy circuits and so these are very
very old things and the idea that you're
in control of them
is
well you're not exactly in control of
them and i would say the less integrated
you are
the less you're in control of them and
the more they're in control of you and
that can get really out of hand you know
uh
you can be like with people who have
obsessive-compulsive disorder for
example which which which is which seems
to be i would say the dissolutive
elements in some sense of the
unconscious the way that it's portrayed
here
poor people with obsessive-compulsive
disorder they can spend half their time
doing things that they can't really
control and they have very strong
impulses to do them and it's very hard
on them to block them you know they
they'll almost panic if those things are
blocked and then you have people with
tourette's syndrome you know that
they'll be doing all sorts of weird
dances and and spouting off obscenities
and
and and and imitating people
without being able to control it and
and
sometimes a little bit of antipsychotic
medication can dampen that down but it's
as if there are these autonomous
semi spirits inside of them that grip
control over their behavior and make
them do things and
you know you find that to some degree in
your own life because maybe you've
become very attracted to someone even
maybe you don't want to be attracted to
the person and then you find yourself
you know texting them when you know
perfectly well that you should be going
to bed and you know you're in a grip of
something and and you can't control it
and that's all part of the unconscious
and all part of what freud was studying